voglio proporvi una sfida osservate
queste due immagini
la prima rappresenta la centrale della
chiesa di santa maria presso san satiro
a milano mentre la seconda rappresenta
una litografia di esser intitolata
relatività ma non notate qualcosa di
strano
probabilmente a primo impatto no ma dopo
un attenta analisi e dopo aver prestato
e la necessaria attenzione vi renderete
conto che in realtà le due immagini
hanno molto in comune
e ora ve lo dimostro
concentriamoci sulla prima immagine
quello che vedete sul fondo della navata
centrale non è altro che un finto curo
perché è finto perché presenta un
illusione prospettica cioè se ci
spostassimo leggermente dal centro
cambiando quindi punto di vista ci
renderemo conto di quello che è
d'inganno ora spostiamoci sulla seconda
immagine
un'immagine che credo che almeno una
volta nella vostra vita abbiate visto in
giro per il web comunque sui libri di
storia dell'arte lo scopo principale di
questa immagine è quello di dimostrare
che anche i nostri stessi sensi possono
ingannarci andando a compromettere ciò
che abbiamo osservato con razionalità
facciamo un esempio
focalizziamoci sulle scale
se però andassimo a capovolgere
l'immagine ci renderemo conto che realtà
ci sono tantissimi altri particolari che
magari in precedenza non avevamo notato
o che semplicemente aveva migliorato ed
è proprio questo la prospettiva la
prospettiva non è solamente qualcosa di
scientifico di oggettivo neanche
soggettività illusione inganno
ed è proprio questo anche la realtà
stessa fateci calcio adesso siete tutti
davanti allo stesso scenario ad
ascoltare le stesse parole ma cos'è che
cambia cambiano le esperienze personali
le quali determinano differenti emozioni
sentimenti o anche il semplice fatto di
osservare un determinato particolare
piuttosto che un altro fa la differenza
dunque la prospettiva è proprio
l'insieme di questi molteplici punti di
vista
ciascuno di noi ha un proprio punto di
vista un punto da cui affacciarsi
osservare nuovi orizzonti ma non credete
che questi orizzonti dopo più di due
anni di pandemia siano stati messi in
discussione la pandemia non ha fatto
altro che capovolgere nostre prospettive
proprio come nella relatività di escher
se penso al copit mi vengono in mente le
due rette parallele che servono per
mettere in pausa un video in effetti il
covip non ha fatto altro che mettere in
pausa il flusso della nostra vita nella
nostra quotidianità
ma proprio come due rette parallele che
si estendono infinitamente senza
incontrarsi mai anche il covip sembra
non avere una fine e per di più ha
provocato in noi una nuova illusione
quella che col tempo si sarebbe tornati
alla normalità
se c'è una cosa che ho imparato da
questo periodo e che nulla è scontato e
soprattutto che le testimonianze di
ciascuno di noi hanno il proprio valore
la propria importanza
qualcuno ne ha approfittato per imparare
a cucinare come dimenticare la caccia al
lievito di birra e alla farina in tutti
i supermercati
altri invece per imparare a suonare un
nuovo strumento musicale o per imparare
a praticare un nuovo p
ma altre addirittura hanno avuto
difficoltà ad alzarsi persino dal letto
ea mantenere uno stile di vita sano ed
equilibrato
oggi sono qui per raccontarvi la mia di
esperienza e lo farò raccontandomi una
mia giornata tipo durante il lock town
sveglia alle 7 mi lavo mi preparo per
una giornata che fondamentalmente
passero davanti a uno schermo e dopo
cinque ore tra una video lezione e
l'altra questa potrà mai fare nel
pomeriggio
beh ovviamente studiare e indovinate
come sempre davanti a uno schermo per
consegnare tutte le varie attività o per
tempo entusiasmante no
ora moltiplicate questa giornata per
cinque volte alla settimana ed il gioco
è fatto
a causa del distanziamento sociale anche
in momenti di svago come ad esempio le
videochiamate con le mie amiche
richiedevano del tempo davanti allo
schermo
ed ecco per questo che persino ho dovuto
acquistare degli occhiali da vista
ma questo non è stato il primo dei
cambiamenti
un altro cambiamento l'ho vissuto per
quanto riguarda l'alimentazione in
effetti durante il covip ho iniziato a
non fare più colazione e addirittura
saltare dei pasti
questo a causa dell'elevato carico di
compiti da svolgere ma soprattutto a
causa della nuova routine sicuramente
più sedentaria
ero sempre stanca e mi sentivo
costantemente occupata ma indovinate chi
ha mostrato realmente interesse nei miei
confronti senza sminuire le mie mozioni
indovinate chi mi ha chiesto come stessi
realmente e se avessi avuto bisogno di
tempo da dedicare a me stessa beh ve lo
dico io nessuno
sapete probabilmente il tempo investito
per la propria salute mentale ha meno
importanza del tempo investito a
studiare in vista di un futuro tuttora
incerto ed è per questo che ritengo
fondamentale l'aiuto il sostegno e
l'ascolto attivo di amici parenti e
perché no anche di un professionista
perché ora più che mai è fondamentale
anche il benessere psicologico
ma dunque possibile rompere questo ciclo
infinito beh la risposta è sì ma è
possibile farlo mantenendo la propria
visione del mondo questo è molto più
improbabile
ed è per questo che sono giunta alla mia
personale conclusione che il mio modo
per uscire da questo loop infinito fosse
capovolgere l'immagine per cercare nuove
prospettive e per quanto questo non
possa cambiare ciò che ci circonda può
permetterci di guardare il mondo da un
altro punto di vista
ho sempre cercato il lato positivo delle
cose e in questo caso questo lo devo la
musica e più in particolare a una band
sudcoreana il bts ho ritrovato la forza
di andare avanti sulle note di life goes
on che significa la vita va avanti
ma per permettere che la vita vada
avanti è necessario un cambiamento e per
permettere che questo cambiamento abbia
inizio bisogna partire dalle piccole
azioni uscendo volta per volta dalla
propria con forzoni io ho iniziato da
quelle che sono appunto le piccole
azioni come ad esempio lo studio e la
lettura ricordandomi però che oltre che
una studentessa su un'aurora un
adolescente un'amica una sorella ma
soprattutto ho 17 anni è tutta una vita
ancora da scrivere
anzi oggi sono qui per proporvi un
esercizio
osservate questo bicchiere vi sembra
mezzo vuoto o mezzo pieno beh quello che
ho imparato è che questo bicchiere può
sempre essere riempito